[Music]
there have been
108 billion homo sapiens born
on earth but you are the very last one
with no other babies
being born after you you would be the
end of the human race
and its legacy what would your life be
like
would the whole world be your parents
and how long would you live
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you were the last child born on earth
the world has stopped having babies
it could be a conscious choice driven by
anti-natalism
the philosophy that humans should stop
having children and
gradually go extinct it might be an
unforeseen consequence of prolonging
human life
or a nasty consequence of environmental
pollution
whatever the cause the human population
has
slowly stopped having children you
are the last to be born and the whole
world knows it
your life would be completely different
than it is today from day one
you'd be a celebrity the whole world
would be
fascinated with your life as you grow up
and
you wouldn't always welcome the
attention you'd be like an
uber reality star with cameras
documenting your
every move people who wish they could
have had kids would be
concerned about your health and
well-being and
they would feel a lot of joy by watching
you grow
you know the saying it takes a village
to raise a child
yeah well you'd be raised by the whole
world
everything would be provided to you food
toys clothing but your
lack of want would come at a high price
your life would be completely controlled
including your schedule what you eat and
where you go
we're talking helicopter parenting times
a billion
yikes now because of your high profile
you'd have a security detail protecting
you from
any suspicious packages poison food and
shady strangers you'd never be alone
this constant control would harm your
emotional well-being as you grow up
children need opportunities to grow and
learn on their own
without chances to make your own
mistakes you could lack some basic
skills
like managing your emotions or dealing
with challenges
and you'd be facing a lot of challenges
and while it would seem like you're
never alone
you would have a very lonely existence
you wouldn't get the chance to play with
other kids your age as you grew up
this would damage your mental and
emotional health even more
playing is an important part of growing
up that helps children develop their
mental
physical and emotional well-being
since you wouldn't be allowed to play
with other kids you
develop depression and feel lonely
hopefully you'd have some animal
companions to provide some of that love
and connection because
your childhood would be difficult
and to add to this you'd have to be
gearing up for the future
you wouldn't go to a normal school
instead you'd be taught a rigorous
curriculum that covers
every skill you'd be learning all kinds
of things from
sewing and agriculture to engineering
and metalwork
why well as earth's human population
begins to dwindle
the systems that support our society
would start to collapse
there wouldn't be enough people to
maintain our complicated food
energy and communication systems
eventually
you'd have to fend for yourself at least
you'd have a long time to master all of
these things
prolonging human life is not science
fiction anymore
sounds like you'll need to be in prime
physical shape
i rely on fitbot to keep me motivated
when i've got tough fitness goals
like that one time when i wanted to ace
a headstand
well fitbot designed a dynamic program
that learned from my past workouts and
adjusted with me and you could get
stronger too
with 25 off a fitbot membership if you
sign up now
fitbot makes me excited about working
out i love their easy instructions the
personalization
and the way it balances out all my
muscle groups for total body fitness
and you don't even need equipment fitbot
has body weight routines if you're
looking to get fit at home
or on the go fitbot creates a program
based on your unique body experience and
environment
so what are you waiting for build the
momentum to carry your fitness journey
throughout the rest of the year with
fitbot get 25
off a membership when you sign up now at
fitbad.me
what if that's 25 off your membership
at fitbot.me what if
researchers have already developed ways
to extend the lives of mice
by up to 40 percent and one of the
world's
top aging scientists dr aubry de gray
thinks
that the first person to reach 1 000
years old
has already been born so you'd have
centuries to master all the skills you
need and
centuries to adjust to the slowly
dwindling population
but if life prolonging technology exists
you wouldn't be the only one with a
super long lifespan
there could be other people alive for
quite a while
and they'd traveled to live near you
creating
the last human community eventually this
community would get smaller and smaller
until at the end of your life you
would be alone you started your life
under the gaze of billions and you'd
ended
as the last human on earth
what would you do with no one else
around
well that's a story for another
what if
you